for sale one dilapidated shepherd's hut
with a rotting frame
and leaky roof sold for 16
000 pounds to an anonymous buyer from
london
leaving a local shepherd squeezed out of
the bidding
and left disappointed auctioneer richard
bromwell had set the price at 800 pounds
he was fascinated to see the bids just
keep going up
and up 5000 to 5005 it goes
all that 8 000 pounds at which point i'm
thinking okay
and shepard farmer stops
so i'd give him over 36 years of being
an auctioneer at charter house
i give him the look i say don't stop now
so off we go again
8 thousand two eight thousand five
shepard's huts went mainstream when
david cameron famously spent
25 000 pounds on his own luxury version
but there are concerns that rising
prices are driving
real farmers out of the market on the
outside
um it does seem quite a funny story like
no dear here's some
wally from the city spending lots of
money on a broken down shepherd but
actually it's
it's quite representative of a much
wider issue
you know if there's lots of competition
from second homers
the price of of livestock is expensive
the price of machinery is
expensive the traditional shepherd's hut
has had
something of a makeover in recent times
this one's
brand new sleeps full with a kitchen
bathroom
and tv it was built by toby and his team
at lower bridge
shepherds huts he now has a three-month
waiting list
tell me about demand at the moment
demands absolutely
um out of this world in fact it's almost
as if
a button was pressed as soon as we went
into the coved lockdown
home the demand for home offices
eventually now more so glamping
as a spike with access to the
countryside starting to feel
more and more unaffordable even to
people who live there
if you want to buy an authentic bolt
hole once home to a real shepherd
expect to see prices rising even further
harriet hadfield
sky news